we knew that Donald Trump would become wacky
and erratic and even more unhinged after his
impeachment acquittal, and it's happening
and it's happening very, very quickly in a
cartoonish.
A Donald Trump has been repeatedly tweeting
this joke video about remaining president
for 20 years.
That's on the cartoonish side.
On the serious authoritarian side.
Donald Trump is now purging impeachment witnesses
who just did what they had to do.
They showed up, they answered questions.
They told as far as we can tell the truth
under oath, under penalty of perjury about
what they knew during the house.
Impeachment inquiry and Trump is now firing
them.
Donald Trump has fired Lieutenant Colonel
Alexander Veneman.
He has fired ambassador to the European union,
Gordon Sunland.
He does not care.
He is an authoritarian.
He is acting like an authoritarian and he
will probably get away with it.
In all likelihood.
Sunland said in a statement on Friday night
quote, I was advised today that the president
intends to recall me effective immediately
as United States ambassador to the European
union.
Now both of these firings, Finland and Sunland
are wacky for different reasons.
First, you have Lieutenant Colonel Veneman,
Lieutenant Colonel as in a member of the military,
Donald Trump and his side claim to support
and believe in and respect and Revere the
troops and see them as trustworthy.
Uh, not when they show up and tell the truth
about Donald Trump apparently.
And now Lieutenant Colonel Veneman is seen
instead of some kind of an untrustworthy sort
of Ukrainian hack who cannot be trusted or
believed or employed.
Gordon Sunland on the other hand, remember
is a major donor to Donald Trump.
Gordon Sundland effectively bought an ambassadorship.
This is actually something that you can do
if you donate a lot of money, and Gordon Sunland
donated about a million dollars to Donald
Trump's inauguration and he bought himself
an ambassadorship, was a big Trump supporter
and again, Trump fired him because he showed
up and told the truth under oath under penalty
of perjury.
And Trump is furious about that.
If you are surprised that Donald Trump is
doing this, you've not been paying attention
because Donald Trump has publicly said his
entire presidency and even more lately that
his style is that of authoritarians.
He's alluded to dealing with traders like
they did in the old days.
He's talking about hanging traders, of course,
also referring to people who aren't traders
as traders, like the whistleblower.
He's talked about how much he loves Rodrigo
Duterte, his handling of the war on drugs,
which includes just extra judicial killings
in the street of not only drug suspect, the
drug dealers, but even drug users.
And meanwhile, Trump is less inclined to behave
like our Western allies, whether it's the
UK, Germany, France, and all of the other
countries that you probably, uh, have heard
me list before in this context.
So should we really be surprised when the
news broke that Trump has an enemies list
and Mitt Romney's on the list and Adam Schiff
is on the list and Jerry Nadler and then now
he fires impeachment witnesses.
Of course, we shouldn't be surprised we have
an authoritarian in the white house.
At the beginning of his presidency, he was
only using authoritarian issue language.
Now he is actually behaving like the authoritarian
that he wants to be.
And of course this is going to be the last
straw, right?
I mean, now all of these Liberty loving righties
are going, Oh no, of course not.
We vote on November 3rd of 2020.
That's the one opportunity we have to hold
Donald Trump accountable.
And sadly there is nothing else I told you
when Donald Trump was acquitted last week
on impeachment and in fact I told you before
because we knew he was going to be acquitted.
He is going to scale up.
He is going to become more erratic.
He is going to become more authoritarian.
He is going to be reinvigorated by the reality.
He's accurately understanding whatever the
hell I do I get away with, okay, sure.
Some of my old friends went to prison, but
he doesn't care about that.
This is merely the beginning.
Just wait until you see what this guy is going
to do between now and the November election
and if he wins reelection, all bets are off
about what a Trump second term is going to
look like